we're learning new details about a
deadly school bus crash in New Jersey
the bus crashed into a dump truck
yesterday on Interstate 80 near Mount
Olive officials say the bus driver made
an illegal turn a student and teacher
were killed 43 other people on the bus
were hospitalized Michelle Miller is at
Morristown Medical Center where many of
the survivors are being treated Michelle
good morning good morning now one child
is here at this hospital in a medically
induced coma
that student along with Eastbrook middle
school classmates were on that bus
headed to a field trip at the Waterloo
village it's an historic place that's
when local authorities say the bus
driver missed the exit making an illegal
u-turn causing the crash I'm gonna need
about 20 and the violent force of the
crash ripped the bus packed with fifth
graders in two pieces and flipped it
over the bus did have seat belts 11
year-old Theo and Seb ski was on board
during the collision a lot of people
were screaming
a few people got out of the windows and
they got out of the emergency exit on
the top emergency responders rushed to
the scene k-9 unit's searched through
wreckage and woods for passengers who
may have been ejected dozens of victims
were taken to local hospitals the dump
truck driver was also hospitalized I I
cried the whole time
it's very motion frantic parents arrived
at the middle school as news of the
accident spread feel bad for the parents
that their kids were on the bus I hope
everything is all well with them while
emotional students worried about their
fellow classmates my best friend was on
that bus and I was so scared it's kind
of hard to explain but I'm scared for my
friends that were on the bus New Jersey
State Police and the Morris County
Prosecutor's Office are leading this
investigation it is unclear if that bus
driver will be facing any charges but we
can tell you that the Paramus school
district has canceled all remaining
field trips for the rest of this year
John Michell thanks New Jersey it's
mandatory to have those seat belts and
there's reporting that they check double
check them before they got on the bus
that's right thank goodness